>>> FORWARD, DRIFT TO THE RIGHT
A LITTLE.
LIGHT -- ENGINE STOP.
QUALITY BASE HERE.
THE EAGLE HAS LANDED.
>> BOY.
>> THAT IS OF COURSE CBS ANCHOR
WALTER CRONKITE REACTING TO THE
MOMENT THAT NEIL ARMSTRONG AND
BUZZ ALDRIN LANDED ON THE MOON
IN 1969.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE SAYING
THAT, WHOO, BOY, IN THE ICONIC
EAGLE LANDER.
FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE THE
APOLLO PROGRAM THEY'RE SHOPPING
FOR A NEW PROGRAM TO GO BACK TO
THE MOON.
THIS ARE THREE DESIGNS FOR THE
ARTEMIS PROGRAM.
MARK STRASSMANN SHOWS US THE
COMPANIIES COMPETING FOR THEIR
CHANCE TO NOW MAKE HISTORY.
>> Reporter: AFTER YEARS OF
DEVELOPMENT --
>> START --
>> Reporter: AND COUNTLESS TESTS
OF ITS ROCKETS AND CREW CAPSULE,
NASA ALMOST HAS ALL THE HARDWARE
IT NEEDS TO SEND ASTRONAUTS BACK
TO THE MOON.
>> THE HUMAN LANDING SYSTEM IS
THE MISSING LINK.
IT'S THE LAST STEP TO COMPLETE
THE PUZZLE FOR OUR RETURN TO THE
MOON.
>> ONCE YOU HAVE THIS --
>> IT'S ALL SYSTEMS GO.
>> Reporter: LISA WATSON MORGAN
LEADS NASA'S FIRST LUNAR LANDER
PROGRAM SINCE APOLLO.
>> WHEN I SEE THIS, IT GIVES ME
GOOSEBUMPS.
>> Reporter: THE APOLLO LUNAR
MODULE WAS ACTUALLY TWO
SPACECRAFT IN ONE.
THE BOTTOM HALF, THE DESCENT
STAGE, LOWERED THE VEHICLE AND
ITS CREW TO A SOFT LANDING.
>> STOP -- LANDED.
>> Reporter: WHEN IT WAS TIME TO
GO HOME --
>> THIS MISSION --
>> Reporter: THE CREW WAS
FERRIED BACK TO THE ORBITING
CAPSULE.
>> WE'RE DEFINITELY BUILDING OFF
APOLLO.
WE SEE WHAT THEY DID.
WE LIVE IN A DIFFERENT ERA.
WHAT MAKES SENSE FOR US TODAY?
WHAT MAKES SENSE FOR NASA, AND
WHAT WILL HELP US TO HAVE MORE
OF A SUSTAINED PRESENCE?
>> Reporter: UNLIKE APOLLO, NASA
WON'T OWN THE ARTEMIS LANDING
SYSTEM.
INSTEAD IT WILL BUY A LANDING
SERVICE, PICKING FROM THREE
DRAMATICALLY DIFFERENT
PROPOSALS.
>> IT'S TIME TO GO BACK TO THE
MOON, THIS TIME TO STAY.
>> Reporter: BLUE ORIGIN,
FOUNDED BY JEFF BEZOS, IS
LEADING A TEAM OF AEROSPACE
COMPANIES THAT CAME UP WITH THIS
DESIGN.
>> THE GOAL IS TO LEARN HOW TO
OPERATE THERE PERMANENTLY.
>> Reporter: BLUE ORIGIN'S BRENT
SHERWOOD TOLD US THAT'S WHY THE
PROPULSION SYSTEM IS BASED ON
WATER, BECAUSE ICE AT THE MOON'S
SOUTH POLE COULD SOMEDAY BE
CONVERTED INTO ROCKET FUEL.
>> BOTH HYDROGEN AND OXYGEN ARE
AVAILABLE ON THE MOON IN THE
FORM OF ICE IN THE POLAR
REGIONS.
AND OUR VISION IS BASED ON
DEVELOPING LUNAR RESOURCES IN
THE FUTURE TO MAKE THESE SYSTEMS
REUSABLE INSTEAD OF BRINGING
EVERYTHING FROM EARTH.
>> IGNITION --
>> Reporter: ELON MUSK'S SPACEX
PROPOSES A LANDER BASED ON ITS
STARSHIP DESIGN.
THE COMPANY'S TESTING IT IN
SOUTH TEXAS.
>> WE'VE HAD A SUCCESSFUL SOFT
TOUCHDOWN ON THE LANDING PAD.
>> Reporter: OUTSIDE, AN
ELEVATOR-LIKE SYSTEM WOULD LOWER
ASTRONAUTS TO THE SURFACE.
AND THEN THERE'S THIS APPROACH
BY DYNETICS, BASED IN
HUNTSVILLE, ALABAMA.
IT'S HORIZONTAL, LOW-SLUNG
LAYOUT, HAS THE CREW HATCH EIGHT
FEET ABOVE THE GROUND.
>> ONE OF THE MOST NOTABLE
ASPECTS OF OUR DESIGN.
WE LIKE TO SEE THAT WHEN NEIL
ARMSTRONG SAID --
>> IT'S ONE SMALL STEP FOR MAN
--
>> ONE GIANT LEAP, HE DIDN'T
WANT IT LITERALLY TO BE A GIANT
LEAP.
>> Reporter: EXECUTIVE JONATHAN
PETTUS GAVE US A TOUR INSIDE THE
MOCKUP.
WHAT WOULD ABOUT THIS WOULD NEIL
AND BUZZ NOT RECOGNIZE?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THEY WOULDN'T
RECOGNIZE THIS MUCH SPACE.
IT'S DOUBLE THE SIZE OF WHAT
THEY HAD.
>> Reporter: IF YOU WIN, WHAT
WOULD IT MEAN TO THE COMPANY?
>> SURE, IT'S GREAT FROM A
BUSINESS PERSPECTIVE.
BUT ULTIMATELY, THE ABILITY TO
HAVE A ROLE IN THIS SORT OF
TREASURE OF THE NATION, THE
SPACE PROGRAM, YOU KNOW, YOU
CAN'T PUTT A PRICE TAG ON IT.
>> IT'S GOT TO BE ONE OF THE
MOST PROUD MOMENTS OF MY LIFE.
>> Reporter: THE APOLLO LANDER
SUCCESSFULLY DELIVERED A DOZEN
AMERICANS TO THE MOON.
NOW NASA HAS TO CHOOSE WHICH
DESIGN WILL LAND AMERICA'S NEXT
MOONWALKERS.
HOW DO YOU BALANCE STICKING WITH
ONE THAT YOU KNOW WORKS AS
OPPOSED TO BEING OPEN TO NEW
WAYS OF DOING THINGS?
>> WELL, BECAUSE IF YOU'VE
ALWAYS DONE WHAT YOU DID, YOU'RE
ALWAYS GOING TO GET WHAT YOU
GOT.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE TO TRY
NEW THINGS.
WE DEFINITELY -- I MEAN, IT
WOULD BE UN-AMERICAN TO NOT TRY
SOMETHING NEW, RIGHT?
>> Reporter: FOR "CBS THIS
MORNING," MARK STRASSMANN,
HUNTSVILLE, ALABAMA.
>> BOY, ALL THREE DESIGNS ARE SO
INTERESTING.
>> VERY DIFFERENT.
I'M EXCITED.
>> THEY'VE GOT GREAT OPTIONS.
>> THEY SURE DO.
>> LIKE WHAT SHE SAID, IF YOU
ALWAYS DID WHAT YOU DID, YOU GET
THE SAME THING.
>> I WISH THEY COULD TRY THEM
ALL.
>> I HOPE THEY DO.